what's going on reject nation Greg Alva
here miss John Humphrey over here this
is John Bailey hey you guys might know
John Bailey the epic voice guy and
what's that on his head honest trailers
wise honest trailers with that he's
trailers and I thought hey since John
Bailey's here he might have recorded the
audio for this but he hasn't seen the
upload yet honest trailers Wonder Woman
are you excited to finally see this I do
excited to finally do these make you
laugh do you watch this on your own yeah
yeah okay or at the very least I shared
pretending yeah I'll do Wonder Woman
today's episode is brought me a paid
extra conditioning at least got a free
bag of em unanimously with complexity
with intelligence with heroism the DC EU
pulls up its biggest success yet by now
patty girl like a hundred years old
superhero movie was like why you lying
down and had a powerful message for
girls say the world look flawless doing
it
that bed might be good he had tolerate
your presence it's this woman kind of
reading we should have said she can read
for an origin story about the Greek gods
inside an origin story for Wonder Woman
inside the silo inside tip the writer
didn't know how to say that mascara or
your and I was like why do I look like I
can't say it you call yourself a nerd
you don't know what just turned into
game at all you have to do is film this
at night is a matter on Amazon so they
prepared their whole lives so quite the
God of War Ares yours they'll get ready
yeah jyb upgrade your your weapons every
30 years at least the boys in the beer
yes every movie they never say the
freakin names right now like some Anna
steel they're like so you're like
Superman they get interrupted think
about Batman so bad I can say that right
I mean I don't come off like James
Cameron is that the only things you
going for
[Laughter]
what is it good for
what is the secretary at the front front
of one Mary you speak a hundred language
and right you know what marriage means
serious this groundbreaking superhero
movie with the smartest Emma's in it
Chris find surprises at the wives in a
performance that gives him his first
lead in a complex leads Rick billets
from a different what can be over yeah
that seems to forget the Germans we're
not the Nazis seriously expects us to
buy this even know this you know what
sorry the reading media's into this
let's just let this one stand on its own
so get ready for a film about balancing
the good and bad in all of us that
contains good and back within itself in
this war but important movie that's no
less important for having Phoenix powers
[Music]
Amazon Prime right here I'm a drunk
Scotsman a sneaky Bridgman a wise old
guy your friend clearly has PTSD
[Music]
thank you I can respond through today's
episode could this voice be any more
addict I've written so well good job
John Bailey thank you I know you're an
old some caramels in here how long ago
do you record these we usually do them
about three four days ahead of time
oh really they try to do them a week but
yeah it's not a lot of time between
recording and being out they start
writing them this at least a month or so
ahead of time Wow by the time I get it's
like version five or six sometimes
they're like real professionals over
there until he makes silly mistake
I can't pronounce that mascara they
spelled Rafael's name Ralph in this
crayon version when they called Han Solo
a bounty hunter in this Griffin like
what are you doing you guys need to be
fired he's not a bad even know that do
you ever get a pitch in jokes I
improvise a lot it's sometimes they make
them in there and sometimes they don't
so I never really know they leave a lot
more of the game stuff that I when I
propose the games guys leave it in a lot
more often when this started playing I
started getting tension in my shoulders
because I was like whoa this guy's few
times I've actually been around you have
a rule if you can memorize the script
for the next one then come here and then
like do you do a whole bunch of
different ones for the names and the
titles they usually like two or three at
least times I think they just like to
have some extra stuff for their
commentaries videos to be honest though
Oh
some of them they never have any
intention of actually using they just
think it's funny can I ask you a favor
can you do me in the butt can you read
some hate comments yeah you guys pick
them out all right Humphrey yeah let's
try to find some hate comments
fortunately we can I just get one hate
comment please come on there's gotta be
some video we did recently okay here
here's one for the all I see is you
trailer oh this is my unit air can you
stop talking in mid trailer your
reaction is fake anyway Oh
you crazy to hear the voice in just
regular room acoustics damn there's so
much love here if you just do you
actually think you're doing a fake oh
that's hilarious it's the same ones that
think the world's flat yeah I swallowed
another man Optimus Prime transform
damn you guys suck for being so nice
okay he read this compliment any comment
move take no [ __ ] says I'm a critic my
god you lost quite a bit of weight very
impressive yeah do you ever just think
to yourself in that voice I do a lot of
voices you guys only know that one
I fill in for celebrities all the time
I've been filling in for Ryan Reynolds
for Deadpool to know about that okay oh
my god hey comment and he spelled your
why are you a positive your talks are so
boring to listen [ __ ] because I read
those comments both scream junkies
thanks for letting us watch that hey
John Bailey thanks for being here John
Bailey John Bailey
John Bailey John Bailey so odd right now
click that notification bill is the air
on it's not click here for more stuff in
there yo yeah he did the whole a patreon
becoming feature on Jake today take care
of people